- Excellent.
Well, good afternoon, everybody,
and welcome to re:Invent.
Everyone having a good time so far?
Enjoying the keynotes this
morning, some cool things?
Excellent.
Well, welcome to Best practices
for serverless developers.
But you know what?
Actually forget the serverless part.
This is actually for all
developers building in the cloud.
Serverless is rarely the default way
to get the most out of the cloud
when building applications.
My name's Julian.
I'm a developer advocate
here for serverless,
specializing in serverless at AWS.
We've got lovely people in the room.
We've got some overflow rooms
in other parts of Las
Vegas at other hotels.
So hello to you all virtually.
And if you're watching this
from the YouTube recording,
which will be posted shortly,
I suppose hello into the future.
So thank you, everybody, for joining me.
Today I'm gonna take you through a story
that actually mirrors
the serverless evolution
of, I don't know, thousands of companies.
And in this talk, we're gonna
follow Amelie's transformation
from a single patisserie
to international success.
And I promise you there's
nothing that I like more
than a delicious pastry.
It's absolutely my weakness
and I'm just thinking
I should have actually brought one now.
So the serverless best
practices I'm gonna teach you
is gonna help to enable
this incredible growth
and understand the
real-world scaling challenges
that every developer is going to face.
And you can see the evolution
from just getting something out there
to a mature serverless architecture.
You can see here five years of growth,
both business growth and
architectural growth and evolution.
Each phase brought new challenges
and also there were obviously lessons.
Notice the dramatic scaling from 40 orders
to 320,000 orders per month.
Huge scale.
And the architecture had
to support this growth.
And we're gonna see
how serverless patterns
helped this transformation.
So things started, Amelie
opened during lockdown
following her absolute baking passion.
A single Lambda function
handled everything,
just 200 lines of code,
basic DynamoDB table for object storage,
for database storage for orders,
and then manual payment
processing via phone calls,
you know, 40 orders per month
from local neighborhood customers.
A great sort of minimal
viable architecture
with basic Lambda functions.
Great way to get started.
Obviously the pay per use model is perfect
for uncertain demand
and, you know, zero
infrastructure management
during a crisis was perfect as well.
2021, the simple architecture still holds,
you know, with some
splitting of Lambda functions
for payment and inventory
tracking, a good idea.
And then, you know, the
first scaling challenges
start to emerge.
Lambda timeouts during the morning rush,
so a performance degradation
during peak powers,
you know, something that's
always hard to troubleshoot,
and team coordination issues too.
2022, more locations, many more orders,
now 42 Lambda functions,
complex dependency chains,
and not enough error handling.
The morning rush cascading failures,
spiking customer complaints.
Performance suffering,
six plus seconds order
processing, that's crazy.
3% failure rate during peak hours, oh, no.
A breaking point that forces
architectural transformational.
And so in,
and with customers getting
frustrated with the slow service.
And in 2024 year was the year
to get down and fix things.
A proper serverless, gradual
architecture sort out,
bringing in Step Functions
for orchestration,
EventBridge for events,
SQS for liable processing,
and reducing 42 Lambda
functions down to just 10,
six seconds down to 400
milliseconds processing time,
and a foundation set for some
cool international expansion.
And it all made a difference
for global expansion.
60 locations across
Europe and North America.
3.8 million orders per year
with great performance and reliability.
Handling 40 times the holiday
traffic spike seamlessly
and a 35% cost reduction
despite three times the growth.
Amelie's passion project goes
to international success.
And so we're gonna follow
Amelie's transformation
through a number of different areas,
show the problem, some solutions,
and some of the lessons learned.
And I'm gonna give you actionable insights
that you can apply to your
own serverless applications.
Now, I'm gonna warn you,
there's going to be a lot here.
I'm gonna go both broad and deep.
So there's gonna be a huge amount of info.
And I've included this QR code,
which is a link to a handy resources page
with the slides from the presentation
and plenty of other reference links.
And I am gonna do the QR code at the end.
So if you miss it, don't worry.
And also, if you are watching
this on the recording,
this is probably not one of those talks
that you wanna watch at double speed.
Maybe half speed's gonna
be a little easier,
but I'll leave that up to you.
A lot we're gonna cover.
So let's start with the foundations,
how to size and organize
your serverless applications.
By 2023, what started as
simple order processing
had become a monolithic nightmare.
A single Lambda function handling orders,
validation, notifications, analytics,
and a whole bunch of more stuff.
Deployment time stretching
to five minutes.
Debugging is I suppose
like finding a croissant
in a bakery full of pastries.
And then a holiday rush incident.
A single bug in the notification service
brought down all the order processing.
That is bad.
And this crisis forced them
to learn proper Lambda sizing principles.
And there's some universal
principles that do apply.
Each Lambda function
should generally have
one clear responsibility,
avoiding a complex
do-it-all Lambda functions.
And what you wanna do is actually size it
for what it needs to do, not
just for your convenience.
Partly. We'll get to that.
But Lambda allocates also
CPU memory proportionally
to memory configuration
and so adding more memory
improves performance
and also may reduce costs.
Package size also directly
impacts cold start times.
So you do wanna make sure
your function's small and
nimble for your performance.
But you can also easily swing the pendulum
to the opposite extremes
with too many functions or repos
or stacks or things to manage.
Resist the temptation
to create these sort of
micro functions prematurely.
Start with cohesive functions
and split only when you
experience real pain.
The 42-function chaos was organic growth
really gone probably a bit wrong.
And same for also stacks and repos.
The goal is a pragmatic approach
for your organizational
and for your current needs,
not your sort of future
theoretical perfection.
And this is actually probably
more an architectural
and an organization decision
rather than just lines of code.
And when you do create clear boundaries,
each team can choose a runtime and tooling
based on their expertise and needs.
And this is unique pretty
much to serverless,
that you can pick and choose
the different kind of things you wanna do.
Maybe the orders team is gonna
prefer using SAM or Java,
the inventory team uses Python
for maybe some great data-heavy workloads,
and the customer experience
team wants to use TypeScript
because they want to use it
for both the front end and the backend.
And so your infrastructure
choices can align
with your team's strengths.
And this extends also to
domain-driven organization
where each domain can
also own its own data
and own its own functionality
and be right-sized for the team,
right-sized for what a team
can effectively manage by itself.
And if you're thinking
and you're building serverless apps,
just use a framework.
It doesn't actually
really matter which one.
Pick the one that works for you.
There are many third-party ones,
or you've got SAM,
which is an extension of CloudFormation
with some simplified syntax,
or CDK to create CloudFormation
in programming languages.
Just use a framework.
It's just gonna make
your life so much easier.
Many people also overcomplicate repos too.
You know, please don't have
a repo for each function,
I beg you, please.
That's gonna be a nightmare.
And you can easily have a
single repo for many services
with separation between, you
know, some domain-specific
and also some shared infrastructure.
You know, the decision
on size for actual repos
is also all about manageability.
So Amelie's transformation
was thinking about sizing,
making a function smaller,
reducing the cold
starts, deployment times,
and also test runs.
40% lower compute costs
through right-sizing.
Right-sizing is the key.
And the key principle being
keep it big until it hurts.
Right-sizing for workloads
organized by business domain
and you can enable team autonomy
in your technological choices.
So next up, you know, Amelie learned
that too much sync, not enough async
was killing performance
during the morning rush,
from sort of blocking
chains to event-driven flow.
2023, synchronous architecture starting
to create some nightmares
during peak hours.
The morning rush brought
cascading system failures
and, of course, frustrated customers.
The synchronous chain meant
one slow payment API call, for example,
blocked everything downstream.
Business impact not good.
23% of orders abandoned.
You know, a huge increase in complaints.
A revenue loss during the
highest traffic periods.
And this crisis forced them
to understand the fundamental problems
with synchronous architectures.
The sequential weight train,
if you look through the
mermaid diagram here,
means every step must finish
before you get a response.
Everything had to complete
in Lambda functions
before the customer got a confirmation.
And so one slow service
affected the entire workflow.
And it's all waiting,
waiting, and waiting.
You know, long chains can
also approach API Gateway
and even Lambda's timeout limits.
Customers abandon orders while
waiting for confirmation.
And this can manifest itself in two ways.
You can have, you know,
one big Lambda function
doing absolutely everything
and it becomes brittle and tough to manage
and also you're paying
for the waiting time
within a Lambda function.
Or actually, I think probably even worse
is multiple Lambda functions in series,
each one a fragile cascading chain.
If a third-party payment service
has a failure, for example,
the rest just stops.
A poor user experience and
tough to come back from.
So Amelie and her team did their research
and realized an event-driven
design would help,
using an event bus for
service-to-service calls,
stopping direct service dependencies,
which allowed for loose coupling,
some independent scaling,
and means failures in one
system don't break the others.
And you can still use async callbacks
to update the original caller
when the work does complete.
Which means bringing in
some other of our serverless friends,
like Step Functions, EventBridge, SQS,
and even AppSync Events,
which is great for the front
end notifications actually.
And what's the mantra for serverless?
You wanna use the best
service for the job.
And so the customer gets an
immediate order confirmation
instead of waiting for
absolutely everything.
And then EventBridge
decouples all the services,
each service processes asynchronously
and publishes its own events while done.
And AppSync Events
provides real-time updates
back to the client as work completes
and so the customer's gonna
see the various progresses,
you know, payment confirmed,
kitchen preparing,
and ready for pickups.
And you get the best of both worlds.
You get that immediate
response back to your client,
plus real-time progress updates.
You get resilience.
The payment delays don't affect
inventory or notifications.
Scalability, each service
can scale independently
based on demand.
And a clear event trail shows
exactly where issues are occurring.
And another thing to bring in
for asynchronous processing
is Lambda's event source mapping.
One of the best use cases for Lambda,
aync processing from a
number of event sources
with direct Lambda integrations.
And event source mapping is a resource
that get events from a source
and ultimately sends the event
to Lambda for processing.
The Lambda service polls
event sources automatically.
There's some content-based filtering,
which can reduce invocations for events
you don't need to process.
The ASM can batch or
group records together
for efficient processing
and then ultimately
invoke the Lambda function
with the batched records.
And there's actually an
architectural difference
between two types of event
sources, queues and streams.
And queues is great for task processing
when each message is independent
and messages are deleted
after the processing.
Streams is more event processing
when perhaps you need multiple consumers
who need the same data or order matters
and messages are retained for replay.
And so a key decision you may have is,
you know, do you have one
consumer doing work once?
Maybe you're gonna use a queue.
Or you've got multiple consumers
or need some sort of replay,
then you're gonna think
about doing a stream.
And the Lambda ESM provides
a bunch of functionality
across all of these event sources.
You've got the filtering,
which I mentioned,
batch controls, including for streams,
being able to split a batch
to find a faulty record,
and then choosing where
to start in a stream,
you know, from the beginning,
from the latest stream,
or at a particular timestamp.
There's some retry and failure
handling options built in,
some analytics for Kinesis,
and platform performance
configuration options.
So a whole bunch.
It's just called an ESM,
but all of this functionality
that is built in.
Sorry, there's the performance
configuration options.
And so Amelie needed a message
buffer during traffic spikes
to prevent system overload.
And so SQS provides perfect decoupling
between producers and consumers.
Lambda ESM automatically polls SQS
and then scales based on the queue depth
and messages are then
gonna be consumed once
and then deleted after
a successful processing.
And SQS just automatically
handles the complexity
of any other message
durability and delivery.
SQS is an incredible service.
And there's a new mode
joining Kafka for SQS
called provisioned mode.
And this allows you to provision
event pollers in advance
to handle sudden spikes in traffic,
and you've got controls
to be able to optimize the throughput.
And there is an additional charge
based on what's called
an event processing unit.
Amelie doesn't actually
need provisioned mode,
but this can be super useful
for high throughput, low
latency queue polling.
So let's look at some
of the best practices
for SQS queue configuration.
You want to set the visibility timeout,
I nearly said invisibility timeout,
the visibility timeout
to at least six times the Lambda function
so messages are available during
processing during retries.
I suggest also setting the
redrive policy for the SQS queue
to, you know, three or probably five
to also give more chances
for successful delivery.
And then for message retention,
make sure it's long enough
to handle any possible
break in the system.
This is not just a new ESM,
but maybe in your whole company
or maybe in a whole region,
so messages aren't lost
during some downtime.
And then you must set a DLQ,
which is a dead-letter queue,
so any messages that Lambda can't process
are sent to this other
queue and then are not lost.
And then you want also some process
to be able to recover
these messages from the DLQ
and be able to replay them
into the main SQS queue.
And from the Lambda ESM side,
you want to also ensure that
you can process messages
and also protect downstream
sources from a search.
That is the point of having a queue.
For processing messages,
the Lambda on-demand ESM can scale
up to 1,250 concurrent
invokes per event source.
And then use provisioned mode, as I said,
if you want faster scaling
and also up to 16 times high concurrency.
16 times high concurrency, that's 20,000,
and that's some impressive throughput
which you can use for your
SQS queues with Lambda.
Filtering also allows you
to only process the messages you need
and you can use positive filtering
to pick which messages
you do want to process,
also negative filtering
for a flexible query
to say which messages you
don't want to process.
And this is a very powerful thing,
saves you money, saves you time.
And it also uses the EventBridge
syntax for filtering,
so it's also consistency.
And also mentioned
obviously this can save
you a bunch of money,
and using this, Amelie
was actually just able
to reduce costs for one
of their ESMs for 92%
by just using filtering.
Batch sizes, I recommend
just tend to get started.
You may as well start with that.
It does mean fewer invokes
and still decent throughput
because the larger the batch
size, the fewer invokes,
and so that's one thing
you need to think about.
See how you go,
but, you know, batch
sizes can go up to 10,000,
which is a huge batch size,
and that can be super useful
in some of your scenarios.
The batch window here
is then to improve the latency
when you actually don't have much traffic.
So you get to process messages
before a batch number is formed.
So you can use these
two different settings
for different use cases.
And then also you've
got the partial batch,
the report batch item failures,
so if you do have a faulty
record in your processing,
you can return a list of
failed records back to SQS
and SQS is then gonna
delete the process messages,
which is more efficient
rather than having to
retry an entire batch.
So then to control the flow control.
This is the rate at which
Lambda consumes the messages.
You want to set the max
concurrency on the ESM
and this is gonna control how
many concurrent invocations
the ESM attempts to send to Lambda,
which prevents overwhelming
downstream services.
These could be things
like databases or APIs
or any third-party services,
which can only handle a
certain amount of throughput.
And this is actually
the all-important
buffering controls system.
And then Lambda reserve
concurrency is a separate setting
which you can set at the
Lambda function level
and this actually reserves
capacity for this function,
ensuring it can scale up when needed
within the account concurrency.
And so you wanna rather
use max concurrency
to manage the buffer,
but if you do want to use both together,
make sure that your reserve concurrency
is higher than the max
concurrency to prevent throttling.
So two different settings
for two different things
and you can use them together.
And then the last bit is
for more error handling.
So this is configuring Lambda
on-failure destinations
for function invoke issues.
And then you may be thinking,
"So, well, why are there actually
two different error handling parts?"
Well, the SQS DLQ captures
messages that fail repeatedly
during polling or processing
and that is on the SQS side,
while Lambda on-failure
destinations captures
invocation failures like
network issues, throttling,
or maybe even if you deleted a function
or you've got some kind of IAM issue.
And so both serve different processes
and should be used together
for comprehensive error handling.
So moving to async is
a powerful architecture
that actually should really
be your default choice
in my opinion.
Avoiding synchronous
chains that can go wrong.
You wanna store first,
you wanna reply quickly
for better user experience,
and then process things later.
And this is a very powerful,
resilient, and stable model.
Understanding also when to
use queues versus streams.
And async also means
better failure isolation,
but you then do need
to think about retries
and not losing any messages.
So next, Amelie learned how
to avoid unnecessary work
through using Step
Functions, orchestration,
and some direct service integrations.
2024, Amelie had successfully moved over
to async architecture
but created a new problem,
42 Lambda functions, as we said before,
including many doing
just simple data
transformations and routing.
That means high compute
costs for operations
that didn't require any sort
of custom business logic,
cold starts affecting performance
for basically crud database updates,
and complex failure scenarios
across multiple function invocations.
And this led to the discovery
that configuration as code
could replace many Lambda functions.
You basically want to avoid Lambda
when you need to use native capabilities
in other services.
Less code to manage.
I don't know about your code,
my code, I want less
code of that to manage.
Your code is probably great,
so you may be good with that.
But for things like simple
data transformations,
direct service-to-service calls,
only routing data from
one place to another,
or simple data enrichment,
you don't need to use Lambda.
If you do have Lambda functions
that serve only as a proxy,
for example, I'm gonna go
through some direct integrations
between API Gateway
and downstream service,
you can optimize that.
So you can see on the right,
API Gateway can actually connect directly
to multiple AWS services,
such as Dynamo, SQS, Step
Functions, and many more.
Once again, no need to use
Lambda just as a proxy.
And I understand that VTL
is a bit of a pain to test,
but also once you do have it
configured, it's done forever.
And for a simple example
like this DynamoDB get item request,
it's easy, cheap, and it's fast.
And more great opportunities
to remove code.
One common pattern that
a lot of customers use
is using Lambda to capture
DynamoDB change events
or change data capture events
from a lot of other services
if they support it.
Lambda then passes the events
and then sends them to another service,
an event bus or API,
for some other downstream processing.
EventBridge Pipes, well, this provides
built-in transformation capabilities.
JSONPath provides a
powerful data manipulation
and filtering only needed events.
You can enrich data as path of the pipe,
do data format, conversions,
transformations.
You can also use Step Functions
and you can also use Lambda
as part of the step as well.
And then it's gonna batch it up
for efficient downstream processing.
And this is perfect for
simple data transformations
that don't necessarily require
complex business logic.
This is it just if you're
using the pipe by itself
without Step Functions and EventBridge.
But, yeah, this, you know,
reduces your Lambda invocations
for basic event processing
and it's really simple to set up.
But actually, the big
winner in Amelie's use case
is using Step Functions.
Being able to remove a
bunch of Lambda functions
for direct service calls.
You can see all of the AWS
SDK actions are available.
So in effect,
there are thousands and
thousands of integrations.
And here's the config to
update inventory in Dynamo.
Just a simple configuration call
that you put in a Step Functions state
and it's really easy to call
and there's a whole
bunch of stuff around it
with no cold states, no cold starts,
and safe retries are also built in.
And there's also built in JSONata support
with loads of these functions,
including some Step
Functions specific ones
like generating a UUID.
So this is super useful.
You wanna count things.
You want to, you know, do up some numbers,
the length and all these kind of things.
No need to have a Lambda function.
You can just use pretty much
free JSONato expressions
to be able to do it.
So these are very powerful ways
to build up a lot of functionality
without having to maintain
any of your custom code.
In many scenarios,
Step Functions is then used in
conjunction with EventBridge,
and Step Functions is great
probably within a domain microservice,
and then the pattern is to finish
what the service needs to do
and that's gonna be whether
that is Step Functions,
whether it's even a Lambda function,
and the pattern is to then emit
an event onto the event bus
and this is then gonna may enable
the event-driven communication
between different domains.
Very powerful model,
allows you to add as
many domains as you need
without sort of trampling on each other.
And if you didn't know,
there are actually two different
flavors of Step Functions.
There's standard workflows,
which can run for up to a
year and are asynchronous,
and express workflows,
which are fast and furious,
and these are specifically
built for high throughput
and they can run for a
maximum of five minutes
and they can also be synchronous.
So super useful for doing
that synchronous calling
we were talking about earlier.
The pricing is different.
Standard workflows are
priced per state transition
and express workflows are then priced
by the number of executions
and memory consumption.
And express workflows also run in memory.
So they're super fast.
And the best part is you can,
and actually you should,
combine standard and express workflows.
You can combine the durability
of standard workflows
with the speed of express workflows.
And so this is perfect for scenarios
where most of the process is long running,
but some of the parts
of your state machine
need some real-time responses.
And so here we can see
the standard workflow
is gonna run start execution
and orchestrate the complete
order processing lifecycle
with a full audit trail as
part of the standard workflows.
And then it's gonna
run the start execution
and run the nested express workflow
to handle real-time inventory validation
in some second time.
And what it can do in
the express workflow,
it can do other cool Step Functions things
like running a parallel state
to check the inventory and the
pricing rules simultaneously
and then it's also using
DynamoDB direct service integrations.
So, again, no Lambda cold starts.
All becomes nice and simple.
But actually, as announced
in the keynote today,
there's a new kid on the block
for asynchronous processing
but still within a Lambda function
with durable functions
being announced today.
And this actually does completely change
the way you think about Lambda functions.
You can now build workflows
in your favorite programming language.
You're able to use checkpointing
to suspend and resume
long-running operations
with item potency just built in.
So this is actually useful
when you have a bunch of
Lambda code in your workflows
and you can now use the
enhanced context object
like I'm highlighting over here
and I'm showing you you can run steps,
you can do parallel processing,
and even wait for callback
all within an async Lambda function,
within the Lambda function,
and you don't pay for
that wait time as well
and they can run for up to a year.
So if your mind's going a bit,
"Hang on, this is all a bit
strange and different for Lambda,"
I'm with you, but this
is a super powerful way,
a new capability that we announced today.
Step Functions, of course, is still great,
particularly for those
direct service integrations.
But if your workflow does
require a lot of your own code
or you'd prefer just managing
your workflow in code
with async checkpointing and resume,
this is certainly worth taking a look.
And my good friends Michael
Gasch and Eric Johnson
are doing a dedicated talk tomorrow
and that's going to be
diving deep into it.
I think it may be at Mandalay Bay,
but I'm not entirely sure.
It's CNS380.
So have that look.
That hopefully should be released
in the content catalog today.
Durable functions is gonna be awesome.
Well, it is awesome.
So going all async helped Amelie
being able to drastically
reduce Lambda functions
and cold starts,
improving latency, better timeouts,
better error handling due to
reliable service integrations,
and a monthly saving of $1,500
just from eliminating
unnecessary Lambda functions.
So this demonstrates the power
of configuration as code
over custom compute.
Remember the good old adage
the best Lambda function
is often the one you
don't even have to write.
So next up, Amelie
optimized Lambda performance
for functions that truly
needed the custom logic
'cause Lambda still is a great service
when you need to use it.
2023, 35 locations,
180,000 orders monthly.
The morning rush created a perfect storm
of performance problems.
Customers abandoned orders faster
than Amelie could even bake croissants,
which meant a revenue
loss, and that's not good.
And this was an existential
business threat,
not even just a technical problem.
And so quick sidebar for
performance and cost,
there's also another
Lambda kid on the block
announced this week,
Lambda Managed Instances.
And this actually gives you
the Lambda operational simplicity
and serverless operational model
to go with EC2's full
ranges and specificity.
We manage the hardware
and it runs in your VPC.
You can choose specialized instance
based on memory or CPU or network
and then Lambda's just gonna manage
in handling this instance.
And there's multicurrency
actually built in,
another minor thing and another change
that Lambda's gonna be able
to support for this model.
But you do need to
handle this in your code.
There's gonna be a lot
of information coming out
about how to do that.
The same timeouts do apply,
but this can be a big cost
saving for at-scale workloads
where you can use also
your EC2 pricing plans
for things like reserved instances.
So this isn't for everybody.
If you're at high scale
and you've got really
steady state functions,
it doesn't spin up as quickly
in being able to burst and
all that kind of thing,
but it at least is an option at high scale
if you wanna be able to manage your costs
when you grow with Lambda.
Again, there's another
dedicated talk on Thursday
from Stephen and Archana that's
going to dive deep into it
and it's worth watching
to understand how concurrency
changes for this model
and definitely check for this one,
and this is in the content catalog.
So let's take a look back
at the normal Lambda function lifecycle.
Lambda creates a new
execution environments,
or for managed instances,
actually, it deploys a container
onto the EC2 instances.
It then downloads your code
or your container image starts the runtime
and then we have to run
your function handler
pre-initialization code
and your first invoke.
And then after that point,
your function is warm
and ready to run the event
that's been sent to it.
There's actually a separation here
between what you can
control and what we control.
And, essentially, everything
up to the init of the runtime
is AWS's problem
and the Lambda team spends
an inordinate amount of time
over the years here,
you know, literally shaving
down to nanoseconds,
trying to improve performance
and trying to make everything
that becomes on our side of the line
faster and faster and faster.
So the parts that you can control
are memory allocation for performance,
your initialization code,
your function handler code,
and then the package size.
So Lambda allocates CPU
power proportionately
to memory configurations up to 10 gig
for on-demand functions
and up to 30 gig for
managed instance functions.
Lambda also proportionately
allocates CPU power
based on memory,
and for managed instances,
you can actually configure
the ratio of memory to virtual CPU
that you actually want for your workload.
For on-demand, once you
allocated more memory
past about 1.8 gig,
you can actually use more calls,
some multi-threading becomes possible.
And it's counterintuitive,
but actually higher memory
often reduces total cost.
If your code is CPU bound,
adding memory improves the performance
and may reduce the cost
and the key is to finding the sweet spot
where performance gains
justify memory costs.
So you add more memory,
it adds more CPU oomph,
and so things can be processed quickly
and that can reduce your costs.
Now, for on-demand,
if you wanna take advantage of more power
with more than one vCPU,
you can use parallel processing
within your Lambda function code.
So if we say here our
processing a batch of records,
doing this sequentially
is gonna take 300 milliseconds
for three records.
And, you know, within your code,
when you use the process
record in your code,
this is gonna process
each record at a time.
But you can actually speed
this up using multiple calls
and running this in parallel.
And so it's only gonna
take a hundred milliseconds
for all three
because you can use promises
to run the code in parallel,
and this is a super unlock
for batch processing
to get the most for your CPUs.
Now, working out the optimal
memory configuration,
you know, that can be a manual process.
You've gotta try all the
options to do it all yourself.
And so Lambda Power Tuning
is an open-source tool
that gives you a data-driven
approach to help you visualize
and fine-tune the memory power
of your Lambda functions.
It runs multiple current
executions of your function
at all the different
memory allocations you pick
and then measures how they perform
and it runs in your accounts,
performing your real function calls,
you know, showing the real cost and speed,
and this helps you to
find the right balance
in an automated way.
Okay, so onto cold starts.
Here, Amelie has her figures
and cold starts affect
less than 1% of invocations
in her production workload
and they primarily
occurred during scaling up
or after function updates.
And so you generally wanna
focus cold start optimization
on latency-sensitive
user-facing workloads.
Async workloads can usually
tolerate some cold start latency
unless you may be using
something like provisioned mode
and you need to do a whole
bunch of throughput processing.
But generally, all those async processes,
you know, if it takes a few milliseconds
or even a second for a
payment notification email
to come through,
you know, nobody's really gonna mind.
And so don't over-optimize cold starts
or background processing functions.
Although, you know, I did mention
there's a cost win for doing this
but, you know, isn't the biggest thing
that you can do for performance.
But there is a bunch of
stuff that you can do
to make your init more efficient.
Focus on what you can control,
the package size, the imports,
and the initialization logic.
You only want to import
specific models that you need.
So you want to avoid
importing huge big SDKs
when you're only gonna
use a small part of it.
You know, if you're
using Node or TypeScript
or that kind of thing,
you can minify production code
to reduce the download time,
lazy initialization if
you do have functions
that do some multiple processes,
and so this can defer
some heavy operations
until they're actually needed
for maybe only part of the invokes.
You can also think about
establishing connections
during the init phase
and then reusing them during
subsequent invocations
when we're talking about warm starts.
But, of course, you do need to think
and you need to make sure that
you can handle reconnections
in your handler
to deal with any of
those stale connections.
Keep-alives also maintain
persistent connections
to other AWS services,
and then also you can cache reusable data
but also you need to think
about cleaning up sensitive data
if you've got, you
know, subsequent invokes
and you've got, you know, information
from different customers
or things like that
or secrets that pertain
to different IAM roles
or, you know, all those kind of things,
you do need to think about that
to make your functions safe.
Now, there are also a lot of
code optimization strategies.
I'm not gonna go through all of these
because each runtime has
specific optimization techniques
and really there's nothing
groundbreaking here.
You know, these are just often,
a lot of them are just
normal code best practices.
You know, Java can benefit
from using SnapStart
and proper SDK usage.
JavaScript or TypeScript
can use modular SDKs
and specifically using the
version three of AWS SDK,
and also things like tree shaking.
.NET can leverage AOT
compilation for faster startup.
And then Python optimization
is often all about your import strategy
and the package size.
But remember, you know, for all of these,
connection reuse is critical
across all the runtimes
to save you time.
There are some native compilation options
that can provide significant
performance benefits.
GraalVM compiles Java
to native executables
with subsecond cold start times.
.NET AOT does a similar kind
of thing for .NET applications.
Now, obviously there are
trade offs with this approach.
There may be some longer build times
and some runtime limitations
and a different sort of runtime
that you maybe need to use.
But this is a useful
thing that you can look at
and this is, you know, often best
for CPU intensive workloads
with predictable execution patterns
so you can run these.
It does obviously
require some code changes
and, you know, the framework
compatibility considerations,
but more and more frameworks
are supporting them.
And so this is most
effective for functions
that are also frequently invoked
or also are cold start sensitive.
And we also have some platform features
like provisioned concurrency and SnapStart
to eliminate cold starts
without any cold changes,
without any code changes,
and we'll get into that.
So provisioned concurrency is
available for all languages.
You configure it then for a certain value,
and then Lambda effectively goes ahead
and prewarms those execution environments,
runs that initialization
process in advance,
and then we're gonna keep
those execution
environments around for you.
As they age out, we're gonna
replace them automatically.
And see, here I've turned
on provisioned concurrency
for this function for version 10.
You can see the inits
are running in advance,
and then when the invokes come in,
they land on those already
warmed execution environments.
And so you won't see a cold start
in front of these environments
and so this is helpful
just before that sort of
8:00 p.m. patisserie rush
from the morning rush
that Amelie would need it.
Two other things,
don't actually pay for provisioned
currency you don't use.
There's a CloudWatch
metric to monitor this,
so don't waste any of your money.
And I pushed over too fast.
And then also, you must use
the function version alias, not $LATEST.
That trips people out when they wonder,
"Why is my provisioned
concurrency not doing anything?"
So when to use it.
This is for applications
that need less than a hundred milliseconds
of startup latency.
So you need to configure the value
for provisioned concurrency,
so it's best for
predictable traffic patterns
which justify the cost
of keeping those warm
environments up and running.
So obviously it's gonna be
good for mission-critical APIs
where any latency variable is unacceptable
or some high-traffic applications
needing consistent performance
during heavy periods.
Now, for implementation,
I suggest you sort of
need to do some research
and understand your execution patterns.
What times of the day do
you need to pre-provision
the provisioned concurrency?
And you can just start
with a static figure
and then maybe evolve it
into something dynamic,
configuring it using
application order scaling
for just when you need it.
And that can be very efficient
to be able to ramp up beforehand
and ramp down afterwards.
And with Lambda's new,
or recent, I suppose a year
ago now, scalability things,
it's really quick to get
provisioned concurrency
up and running in advance.
So then Lambda SnapStart
for Java, Python, and .NET
is another platform feature
that runs the cold start process
when you publish a function in advance,
so not actually just before an invoke.
And so when you need
to invoke the function,
it's gonna resume the snapshot
and it's generally gonna
do this in under a second.
And so it makes it perfect
for cost-sensitive applications
with unpredictable traffic.
There's no additional cost,
which makes it a great workload
where provisioned concurrency
would be expensive.
Functions with heavy runtime startup
or loading heavy dependencies,
they're gonna be the ones
that see the biggest benefit.
Java is gonna see great performance gains
to, you know, having to start up the JVM.
Python is gonna be benefit significantly
when loading big ML frameworks.
And .NET gains from eliminating
the compilation delays.
And remember, again, to
target a function version
and you also cannot use both SnapStart
and provisioned concurrency
at the same time.
So what can you do to actually
make that snapshot process
as efficient as possible?
For Java, what you can use
the beforeCheckpoint hook
to preload dependencies
and initialize resources
using the init phase.
And this actually uses
the CRaC runtime hooks,
which is from an open-source project.
And there are two ways to do this.
You can actually use invoke priming,
which does have the highest performance,
but make sure that you then use stub data
and your code must be item potent
as actually running real live invokes
for your Lambda function to set this up.
Or you can choose to use class priming
and this is then gonna load classes
without actually the method of execution.
So two different ways,
but you wanna run as much as
you can in this init process
so that's gonna optimize your invokes.
And for .NET, it's actually you
want to run multiple invokes
as part of the init
using the RegisterBeforeSnapshot,
which is what makes .NET's
snapshot really effective.
And literally you run wanna run probably,
you know, maybe even 10 or 20 times
and the signals .NET runtime
to perform tiered
compilation aggressively.
It's sort of, I suppose, think
of saying to the runtime,
"This code is hot.
Optimize it as aggressively as you can."
And again, you know,
use dummy or stub data
to avoid side effects during warmup
because you are running real invokes.
And this, you know, works
with many frameworks as well.
So there's some universal
best practices for SnapStart.
You wanna reestablish network
connections after restore.
State isn't gonna be guaranteed.
You wanna generate unique IDs and secrets
after the initialization,
and then you obviously wanna refresh
credentials and timestamps
then in your handler.
And, of course, only executed
init code paths are captured.
So you want to use those
runtime hooks we spoke about
to warm those critical paths.
And then again, you must use
function versions, not $LATEST,
and obviously you wanna test
with your realistic workloads.
And CloudWatch Metrics can be your friend
to validate the performance improvement
with your business impact.
Snapshot is actually a really great,
you know, quick and easy win
to be able to improve
cold start performance.
Now, another optimization tip,
just upgrade your runtime.
Seriously, it's often one of
the simplest things to do.
You know, in this example,
upgrading Python had a
dramatic increase in latency,
which improves performance
and reduces cost.
You know, languages are
continually evolving
and help keeping up to
date with runtime means
you also get the best
performance for your buck
and, of course, there's
a security implication
for this as well.
So a systematic approach
delivered dramatic improvements,
starting with memory right-sizing,
the main kind of thing,
the biggest impact, the
easiest implementation.
Code optimization
provided additional gains
through better resource utilization.
Cold start mitigation ensured
consistent performance
during traffic spikes,
and native compilation provided
that last little performance boost
for CPU intensive workloads.
So next up, how Amelie
built resilient systems
through proper failure
handling and error recovery.
Now, lots of locations, 35 of them,
processing thousands of orders daily.
That holiday rush I spoke
about earlier created
this sort of perfect storm
of cascading failures.
Payment issues, a crashed order system,
no notifications, manual recovery,
obviously this is a big business impact.
Lost revenue, angry customers,
a confused kitchen.
What's going on?
So, of course, this crisis
forced them to understand
that resilience is also
a business imperative.
So with all of this,
the most important thing to
think about is item potency.
Item potency ensures
operations have the same effect
whether executed once or multiple times.
And this is critical
for distributed systems
where retries, duplicates,
and out of order processing occur.
Basically, I don't want
to be charged twice,
so please build all your
item potency operations.
But you do then need to think
about your item potency,
what that item potency key is,
that sort of unique
transaction identifier.
You know, is it gonna be an order ID
or something that you can
use for your item potency?
And many AWS services provide
built-in item potency,
which you may not know about.
DynamoDB, you can use conditional rights,
and so this is gonna prevent
duplicate operations.
SQS FIFO queues can use a
message deduplication ID
for automatic deduplication.
And did you actually
know for Step Functions,
you can just specify an execution name
to prevent duplicates?
So you've got a Step Functions workflow,
just provide the name.
If the same name has happened before,
and you can use, you
know, maybe an order ID
or that kind of thing,
Step Functions won't run it.
So simple and a lot of people don't know.
And, of course, Lambda durable
functions is another way
because item potency is just part
of the checkpointing part of it.
And for your code,
Powertools for AWS Lambda,
please, this is a tool and library
for .NET, for Python, for Java,
and for Node and TypeScript,
just use this for your functions.
It has a huge amount of functionality.
Item potency is included
and it actually just uses
DynamoDB behind the scenes.
You just set it up in your code
and item potency is handled for you.
Super useful.
So we already covered SQS's deal queues
and Lambda destinations.
This is all part of your
failure handling toolkit.
And remember, retries are
all built into Step Functions
when using Step Functions
set as configuration,
part of your failure and error handling.
And you have retry,
you've got catch dates,
you've got choice and parallel states,
and this can give you a whole lot
of error handling goodness.
If you're building saga patterns
or other kind of things,
a whole bunch of functionality.
And so Amelie's order processing workflow
has comprehensive error
handling at each step
to preventing single failures
from bringing down the
entire order process.
And if you prefer the full code approach,
you know, we've got new options now
with Lambda durable functions.
So next, Amelie gained complete visibility
into their serverless systems
through advanced observability.
You know, 35 locations,
system visibility gaps across services,
difficult to trace orders,
gonna identify bottlenecks
causing the slow processing,
where they're coming from,
or trying to connect actually
some of the technical metrics
also to the business impact.
And a breaking point was
an undetected payment issue
which happened for two hours.
Resulted in, you know,
hundreds of lost orders
and $12,000 in revenue loss
during the dinner rush.
Now, that's not a good thing
that any fledgling business wants to run.
No one wants to fly blind.
Now, observability is a massive topic
and it's in a fast-moving place,
and there are many
breakouts here at re:Invent,
which is all about observability.
So I'm just gonna give
you some of the new things
that you can explore to
find out to help you out.
I love Charity Majors' work.
She works for Honeycomb
and she talks a lot more
about more than just the
pillars of observability,
but a bunch of different signals of data
which you can use for
unified observability data.
And seriously, read up Charity Majors,
read everything she writes about
and talks about observability.
She's an absolute guru and amazing.
So you've got things like metrics
and logs and traces and
events and profiling
and they can all be part of these signals
and, you know, other
kind of business things
that can come in.
Observability is a big thing.
But the thing I want you to take away
is you wanna really focus on
embedding business context
in all of the signals for
rapid troubleshooting.
So this isn't just a
technical monitoring thing.
This is observability,
and the business is very much part of it.
So this shifts your thinking
from not sort of only monitoring failures
to being able to answer
questions about individual things
to understand your business.
Again, Powertools is your
friend here for observability.
It just makes things so much easier.
You can import the
libraries really quickly,
configure up your service names,
and then it's easy to set up the logging
and the metrics as well.
And this is then gonna use
structured logging behind the scenes
and using the embedded metrics format
to create metrics from the
logs entries automatically.
A single log write creates
both searchable logs
and CloudWatch Metrics
and this is also faster and cheaper.
And this is a great way then
to incorporate that business
context I was talking about
like an order ID for the logs
without having it as a metric dimension,
which is gonna be pricing.
So here we see both entries
written to CloudWatch logs
in a single log stream.
The regular logs are queryable
with CloudWatch Insights for debugging.
And then the EMF entry
lets CloudWatch automatically
extract the metrics from it,
a powerful two for one.
CloudWatch Metrics also
has a bunch of new stuff
like powerful tag-based automation
with filtering on alarming
instead of configuring
individual function alarm tags,
and this makes it way easier.
And it's cheaper.
You've got one alarm
instead of, you know, 50
and individual alarms
reduce the CloudWatch costs.
There's really fancy querying
capabilities now available
and a cool new dynamic dashboard
where you can actually
build up your dashboard
and then you can just
select your environment
with a dropdown selection
and it changes all in real time.
The query generator
converts natural language
to CloudWatch Metrics SQL
and allows you to refine existing queries,
which I found so much easier.
The metrics history has also
been extended from three hours
all the way up to two weeks
for historical analysis.
CloudWatch Application Signals
is also something to look at,
a new observability solution
which is based on open telemetry,
and this can also
automatically discover services
and it's got a more advanced service map
and a whole bunch of other things.
So I can't do CloudWatch justice here
and I don't want to, you know,
flick over kind of things.
So the awesome Joe Alioto
has done a great video
on all the new things
and there are gonna be new things
announced this week as well.
So I just really suggest you taking a look
'cause there's a huge amount
that's gone on in observability this year,
which can really help
you with your business.
So talking about OTEL for Lambda.
Well, the X-Ray SDK is coming to an end.
X-Ray as as service continues,
but it's moving to OTEL
for instrumentation
using the AWS distro for open telemetry.
If you want to start
looking at this for Lambda,
there is an ADOT layer,
but we actually recommend using
the Application Signals Lambda layer.
It's actually an enhanced version of ADOT
specifically optimized for Lambda
with better performance and
lower resource consumption.
You can also configure
the Application Signals
to use only the OTEL
libraries for instrumentation
without all the other features
for Application Signals
by just setting an environment variable.
So moving to OTEL at the moment
does mean a little bit more money
and a small cold start penalty,
but if OTEL is your thing,
at least we've got some good options.
And, of course, we love
partnering with others.
So you can use your favorite
third-party tools with Lambda
to get the observability you need.
And so Amelie did a lot
of observability work,
more than I can cover here in the time,
but it all pays off.
A transformation from disaster prone
to a highly reliable system.
Better reliability, recovery
times, less tail chasing.
You know, Black Friday
2024 had zero outages
during a peak traffic
and, you know, far less
customer complaints
to better error handling.
Next, let's talk about costs
and how Amelie optimized costs
using design while scaling.
But Amelie started the serverless
journey with excitement,
but faced unexpected cost challenges.
This can happen to you.
Monthly AWS bills jumping
from $200 to $2,000
without much warning.
During a growth phase,
Lambda invocations spiking crazily.
Maybe overprovisioned Lambda
functions with too much memory.
CloudWatch logs accumulating
gigabytes of data daily.
Each new restaurant adding
more and more infrastructure costs,
and data transfer and
storage costs all adding up.
And Amelie realized that in serverless,
architecture decisions
really impact costs.
Understanding serverless
pricing is crucial
for cost-effective
architectural decisions.
Lambda is on demand.
It uses pay per use model
with charges for requests and
then also your compute time.
So init time is charged
from this year to remember
and this was to avoid complexity
with some inits charging
and some inits not being charged.
So it's all across the
board, inits are charged.
And then per millisecond
billing is super powerful
with each invoke
and, of course, there's
inits charged separately.
And so this is cost-effective
when there are gaps and work to do.
And you can also consider
Lambda managed instances
for bigger steady state workloads
where you can run Lambda scale
in a cost-effective manner.
Now, while Fargate uses time-based model
with charges for CPU and memory for hour.
You pay for what you provision.
Now, I didn't have enough time today,
there was enough to talk about,
to go into all Fargate best practices,
but it is a super great
solution for many workloads
when you don't want to
use an event-driven model.
And it can also be cheaper
than Lambda at scale.
Continuous processing or
long-running predictive workloads
are gonna favor Fargate
and sporadic, event-driven
processing is gonna favor Lambda,
even though Lambda can scale up
to super high workloads.
This is cost things that you can work out.
For Step Functions,
express workflows can also
be significantly cheaper.
Amelie's using both,
but you can see how
pricing can be cheaper.
Many more invocations
for 1/20th of the cost
in this example using express workflows.
So also take a look at your
existing state machines
and see whether you can
potentially save some money
and then consider using
express workflows first
when you're building
your next applications.
And optimizing your logging
costs can be an easy win.
AWS rolled out tiered
pricing for logs this year.
Basically, the more you log,
the cheaper it gets per gigabytes.
The best part, it's automatic.
You don't have to do anything.
It's just gonna be cheaper.
Use structured logging
with smart log levels.
Maybe you're gonna set
info as your default.
Maybe you're gonna sample
debug logs sparingly.
And use Lambda Powertools
for efficient logging
without the custom code overhead.
You also want to match
your retention to reality.
Maybe you need 30 days
for dev, 90 for staging,
three to six months for production.
I don't know, it's gonna
depend on your workload,
but basically stop paying for
logs you're never gonna use.
Also, don't log what you don't need to.
Skip massive payloads in your logs.
Just log key identifiers instead.
You can also archive to S3
now for long-term storage
or log directly to Data Firehose
when you want high throughput
and maybe wanna send the logs
to some other destinations.
And lastly, monitor those costs.
You wanna set CloudWatch billing alerts
and use Cost Explorer to identify
your biggest log spenders.
So there's lots that Amelie
did which reduced costs,
which also we covered in
some other kind of sections.
Right-sizing was the biggest flex
to not pay unnecessarily.
Filtering is obvious to not
just have to work on things
that you don't need to,
but it's gonna be able to, you know, avoid
a whole bunch of costs unnecessarily.
And also using compute savings plans.
Amelie is looking to explore that as well.
She hasn't quite done that.
That's another kind of option.
And so with some simple optimizations,
you can make a big difference on costs.
Every architecture decision
has a direct cost impact.
Understand your pricing models,
monitor your usage patterns,
and then optimize based on
your actual requirements.
So next up, integrating AI capabilities
into their serverless architectures.
This is the year of 2025.
I don't think anybody at any
conference in IT in the world
is unable to talk about gen AI.
But it is an important
and I think an interesting
part that we can look at.
By this year, Amelie's 60 global
locations faced challenges
traditional automation
just couldn't solve.
If you've got 12,000 monthly inquiries,
that's gonna overwhelm your support team.
You know, if you need
to particularly handle
multiple languages.
You know, 4.3 million orders
with minimal personalization.
Maybe you can do some more with that,
so you're missing some
revenue opportunities.
And manual decision-making
for pricing and inventory.
Amelie starts to look
to AI to help with this
and maybe take their
business to the next level.
But Amelie also knows that AI is a journey
to also work out what's
real and what's hype.
And I know we're all probably
struggling here at the moment
trying to work out what
the best use case is
in your business.
And, of course, all of AI could
be a whole nother session.
But I'm pretty sure here
at re:Invent this year,
there are gonna be a few
other gen AI sessions
to help with whatever gen AI things
you're gonna be looking at.
So first thing they realized
in the investigations
is that gen AI is just another workload.
The same rules apply.
What do you need to do?
You need to protect endpoints.
You need to think about quotas.
You need to handle security.
You need to think about performance.
Everything you know and love
about serverless still applies.
There's less infrastructure to manage,
variable compute demands.
Pay per use are all good.
Using async event-driven
processing allows AI
to respond to business events
like orders, inquiries
and inventory changes.
Automatic scaling handles traffic spikes
without capacity planning.
And your existing serverless
skills transfer directly.
Event-driven architectures,
cost optimization, and observability.
And Bedrock, as an example,
is a serverless service.
You know, the pricing is
based on input/output tokens,
automatic scaling to demand
with enterprise security
and compliance built in.
And in fact, if you
look around the industry
at the gen AI landscape,
most of it is just good
old-fashioned serverless.
Any kind of model you're using,
it's all token-based
pricing, all pay per use.
So, yeah, serverless,
you know, is definitely very
applicable in the AI world.
And, of course, you can integrate Bedrock
with all other serverless services.
For compute, there are
plenty of different options
and Step Functions is great
if you wanna do some complex
multi-step AI workflows.
Event routing and response
distribution are needed
with EventBridge to help.
And DynamoDB and S3 can also be used
for storage of many, many things.
And then we wanna understand
the sort of main two parts
with AI that are relevant:
agents, the orchestrators,
and tools as the executors.
Agents run in an orchestrated loop
to do something you've
basically told it to do.
It calls the tools to do the things,
then figures out what the next stage is
to satisfy your request.
And they're often long-running,
needing to maintain state, the agents.
And so we could decide
whether agents are short or long-running
and pick the best serverless
service to do this,
whether that's gonna be Lambda or Fargate.
But what do we actually learn
from a decade worth of serverless
is rather use a service that
is purpose built for the job.
And so Bedrock AgentCore
is built for running agents
and it abstracts a lot
of the heavy lifting
so you can head up the
stack for a managed service
the true serverless way.
AgentCore's got a bunch of capabilities,
a secure managed runtime
to run your long-running
agents with pay per use.
And that actually runs
a Lambda Firecracker instance for you,
all abstracted and behind the scenes.
So we take in the learnings
from other serverless services like Lambda
and applying them to more things.
An MCP gateway to connect
to existing APIs and tools,
conversation memory, inbound
and outbound identity.
AgentCore is also framework
and protocol agnostic.
And the cool thing is it's
a bunch of capabilities
you don't need to build yourself.
And also you don't have to use them all.
You can just use one, use two,
use all of them, doesn't matter.
It's built very specifically
that you can pick and
choose the useful things
that you're gonna do.
So for identity, for example,
sure you could spin up
a DynamoDB instance,
store your conversation
history and manage that,
or you could just use Identity
and it's all built in with semantic search
as part of the package.
And then tools,
and these are what the agents
call to actually do something.
And the tools are actually
what you likely already have.
Maybe that's something behind an API
that reads or writes data from a database,
does some action, connects
to your private data,
something on-prem, something
within your own VPC.
Actually, the tools are
the deterministic part
within gen AI.
You know exactly how they work,
what functions they can perform,
and they're gonna avoiding hallucinations.
And in fact, I think you
actually wanna focus more
on the tool side.
Even if you don't have robust APIs yet,
but with MCP or something
like that in front of them,
you've actually got more freedom
to be able to experiment
as APIs are forever.
But because MCP abstracts them,
you can have things internal
that you can expose externally
without having to worry
too much about your APIs.
You want to worry about your APIs,
but having this MCP intermediary layer
can be super powerful.
And, of course, Lambda is great for tools,
standalone or behind an API,
because they've got fast startup,
they can connect to anything,
things in your VPC, things anywhere,
your data, your VPC,
and they are super secure.
So just two examples I've
got here, what Amelie builds.
A new customer service AI agent
to integrate with existing functionality.
The customer inquiry goes
into an agent using MCP.
AgentCore manages the AI
agent runtime with Bedrock
while using the Gateway to connect to APIs
and then to connect to Lambda
functions as status tools.
So AgentCore is gonna
handle the orchestration,
the state management,
and the observability automatically
and the team could then focus
on building the actual tools
and not having to worry too
much about building the agents.
Another intelligent recommendation
was a good idea they had.
This is based on an order created event
which spurs EventBridge into action.
Lambda processes context.
Bedrock is then gonna
provide some AI analysis
and DynamoDB is gonna store the profiles.
Recommendations can adapt during sessions.
So this is basically when
someone does a payment,
it's gonna pop up, "Ooh, do
you also want to buy this?"
And so it can use time
or weather or location
or cross-location insights.
Contextual, personalized upselling
is really good for customers
and also for their business.
And so far, Amelie's AI's
results are a good start
and they are welcome.
70% customer service automation
using AgentCore and Lambda tools.
12% revenue growth by
using their upselling
with what's in your cart.
And also a faster development,
you know, focusing on the tools
and not on the infrastructure,
and cost efficiency,
pay per use for the agents and the tools.
And haven't got time as well,
but there's not even including
the AI coding assistance
that the team is taking on
using Kiro for spectrum development,
which is literally speeding up everything
and building really good
production-grade applications,
and then using the serverless MCP server,
which you can connect into Kiro
and, in fact, any MCP client,
and this really uplifts your
serverless best practices.
You can use natural language.
You can query about MCPs.
You can query about what
infrastructures code tools,
Lambda optimizations, Step Functions,
all these kind of things
built into that MCP server.
I really suggest you take a look.
So after all that, I'd said
I'd cover a lot and I did.
Let's recap to see what
Amelie's journey revealed.
Is everybody okay?
You're hanging in there? Good.
Serverless works at any scale,
from 40 orders to 320,000.
Serverless architectures had to evolve
to support this growth.
But serverless, of course, was
the best way to achieve this.
We had some core principles.
Here's the QR code again
for the presentation
and more handy jumping off links.
Right-sizing, matching the function repo
and stack size to your workload,
async over sync,
EventBridge and queues for resiliency
with still faster customer updates,
avoiding work if you can using
direct service integrations,
Step Functions, filtering
early using batch operations,
performance optimization,
optimizing those cold starts,
function code optimization,
platform functionality
with provisioned
concurrency and SnapStart.
Failure handling.
We've got retries, deal queues,
circuit breakers, a whole bunch of things.
We've got observability, logs,
metrics, signals with business context
and lots of new CloudWatch goodness,
and cost.
Being architecture, every
decision has a price tag.
And gen AI, just another workload.
Your serverless skills apply.
And these principles
also apply at any scale.
So what could be your next steps?
Well, this week, maybe next week,
I think you're gonna be
broken from re:Invent,
but pick one Lambda function to optimize.
Add some structured logging,
including some business context.
Implement proper error
handling using retries and DLQs
if using SQS.
Check function sizing.
Make sure you correctly size your memory.
And use EventBridge,
not direct invocations.
And then once you start there,
you can build some momentum.
Migrate one sync workload to async.
Build robust workflows
considering Step Functions
or Lambda durable functions.
Implement some event filtering,
save yourself some money.
Review and optimize those costs.
And then also document your patterns
to be able to scale out your efforts.
There are lots of other
sessions going on this week.
Lambda managed instance
and durable functions I
mentioned in the talk as well.
There's also a leadership session,
Building the future with AWS Serverless.
And a shameless plug,
I'll be back tomorrow
with a Lambda principal engineer
and we are gonna be talking in detail
all about how events
travel through Lambda,
specifically with polling,
and that's gonna be back here tomorrow.
This link also provides a
bunch of additional information
to continuous serverless learning.
It's got links to Powertools,
a bunch of announcements,
Serverless Land patterns.
If you've ever used that,
that is infrastructure as code
and function code examples
for, you know, all the serverless services
and you just be able to do them
and a whole bunch of them you can use
directly in your ID as well.
Super useful.
Serverlessland.com as
well is the best website
to keep up to date with all
things serverless on AWS.
Lots of cool stuff that
you can read over there.
But most importantly, thank
you for joining me today.
I appreciate you taking out the time
if you've had to move across Vegas
and come to another venue.
Thank you so much.
I also really appreciate
if you could fill in the session survey.
If you're hungry
for, you know, more deep
technical contents, more broad,
and more kind of things,
this really lets us know
the kind of things you'd be interested in.
So I would appreciate, of course,
a nice five in that as well,
but also be honest with what you think.
So thank you really much.
I hope you enjoy the rest of
your day here at re:Invent.
Plenty more to learn, plenty
more people to connect to.
I encourage you to use
the hallway track as well.
Sit down with somebody at lunch
and find out and talk
about your kind of things,
talk about serverless,
and enjoy the rest of your week.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)